dem attentäter von halle wird der
prozess gemacht er wollte juden ermorden
seine tat filmte er selbst mit der
helmkamera für gleichgesinnte und für
potentielle nachahmer er aber und im
livestream die juden seien schuld am
penis muss und der sei schuld dass
migranten bald die deutsche bevölkerung
ersetzen würden im hintergrund seine
tiraden hört man einen song der den
attentäter verherrlicht der in toronto
2018 mit seinem bett zehn menschen tod
fuhr
im verhör gab der toronto attentäter an
ein inzell zu sein er benutzt die code
wörter stacy es für frauen und chats für
attraktive männer
wer sind diese in eine abkürzung für in
monterrey sally bates männer die
unfreiwillig ohne sex leben und in
online foren ihren hass auf frauen aus
leben zwei jahre lang erforscht veronika
kracher die toxische ideologie dieser
subkultur in der insel ideologie ist ein
leben ohne sex und ohne beziehungen das
schrecklichste was jemandem passieren
kann
das leben ist verloren und grässlich
weil man keinen sex hat und dieses leid
wird eben frauen zugeschrieben frauen
schlafen nicht mit mir deswegen sind
frauen für das leid das ich empfinde
verantwortlich deswegen habe ich das weg
frauen zu hassen und im schlimmsten fall
sache für die mir erfahrene kränkung der
sex losigkeit zu nehmen
eine narzisstische kränkung die von den
anderen die frauen haben bz sex ihm
immer wieder vor augen geführt wird
seine rache gilt allen frauen den stacy
früher vor dem feminismus sie meine 1955
gab es für jeden mann eine frau egal wie
unattraktiv der mann war
heutzutage wollen alle frauen nur die
gut aussehenden und interessanten die
sogenannten jets das heißt inzells
hätten gar keine chance in selb sagen
dass ihnen der wert zum alpha man von
anfang an verwehrt ist sie gehen davon
aus dass weniger attraktive menschen
systematisch diskriminiert werden alle
frauen seien hyperguard schlafen mit
vielen alpha männern frauen werden
herabgewürdigt gast und doch könnte nur
sex mit einer frau einen inzell erlösen
eine ausweglose situation ins netz
stellen sich selbst in ihren minister
in der gegenüberstellung mit einer
grotesk überzeichneten maskulinität
können sie nur loser sein
in ihrer eigenen community die sich
nicht selbst bestätigt sondern
destruktiv ist stehen sie unter druck
posten fotos von sich auf der seite way
to be ready for use postet bilder von
dir und lass dich bewerten sei auf
beleidigungen gefasst inzells bestatten
sich in ihrem selbsthass depression und
suizide werden belacht manche gehen
soweit sich eine operation zu
unterziehen
den kiefer brechen zu lassen um zum chat
zu werden und mit einer frau sex haben
zu können
ein kapselt sich von einer realen welt
ab und zieht sich in die echo kamal
eines internets zurück in deren in denen
man permanent in seiner eigenen
ideologie in seinem eigenen denkens
bestätigen wird man klärt sich selbst
ein loch aus dem es schwer ist wieder
herauszukommen
für ihr stereotypes frauenbild haben sie
festgelegte merkmale die meisten sind
negativ das ideal ist die jungfrau
mädchenhaft gerne minderjährig wie das
cat girl eine männerfantasie aus der
manga welt kätzchen und mädchen
anhänglich und unterwürfig beim halle
attentäter das sehnsuchts bild seiner
belohnung im jenseits
der event liste seines
bekennerschreibens hat man den hinweis
dass er darauf wartet dass ihn kehrt
girls in walhalla erwarten
das frauenbild der insel eine reaktion
auf emanzipation und feminismus frauen
die es wagen sich in der öffentlichkeit
feministisch zu artikulieren oder
überhaupt in der öffentlichkeit zu
agieren oder generell in männlich
dominiertes fehlen wie die politik oder
einen intellektuellen bereich oder
videospiele einzubringen frauen werden
als team oder als löcher oder als
toiletten bezeichnet sie werden mit dem
sachlichen promeniert tituliert frauen
sind nicht wirklich menschen sondern
ausgeburten des absoluten bösen was mich
in meiner recherche sehr schockiert hat
war ein beitrag auf dem insel forum lux
max dort an der auf dem die user bilder
und videos von vergewaltigte frauen
gepostet habe nervt den foren user dame
sexuelle straftaten begangen zu haben
wie vor einer frau masturbiert haben den
revidierten penis in einem überfüllten
bus an einer frau gegeben zu haben sich
sexuell an menschen vergangen zu haben
und na ja der gipfel dieser gewalt ist
der vermieter oder eben in celadna der
halle attentäter hat ein antisemitisches
kein insel attentat begangen doch seine
radikalisierung hat verknüpfungen zur
insel szene
ich halte das für einen elementaren
bestand
unsere arbeit dass wir uns mit neuen
phänomen wie zum beispiel der insel
bewegungen befassen und uns darauf
einstellen
das ist eine online subkultur mit
infantiler welt bespiegeln dennoch
werden einige von ihnen zu potenzielle
terroristen
man muss sie im blick behalten